today we're talking about two
budget-friendly iPads the brand-new 2019
iPad Mini and the 2019 iPad iPad what's
going on guys my name is David Tommy and
welcome back to the channel today we're
talking about two iPads and two iPads in
particular we're talking about the brand
new 2019 iPad Mini which comes in a 7.9
a Retina display and costs about 599
Australian dollars which for all your US
viewers is about 400 u.s. we're also
talking about the brand new 10.2 inch
iPad iPad it's the original iPad the one
that only has the iPad name it starts
from about 529 Australian dollars but
this one here being a cellular version
goes all the way up to seven hundred and
twenty-nine dollars for about 500 US
this one isn't so budget-friendly the
Wi-Fi only version compared to the iPad
Mini is pretty much price for price if
you're looking for a budget-friendly
iPad chances are you're not really too
interested about the specs yes they're
important but they don't mean too much
it's really about how you're going to
use your iPad and what you're planning
on using the iPad for if you are
interested in the specs spoiler alert
the iPad Mini is a much better purchase
overall it has a better user rated
battery life it has a much better screen
resolution and it also has a much better
forward facing camera a quick little
side-by-side test here with the two
iPads on each side the iPad Mini and the
iPad iPad the camera itself is pretty
decent you're not really going to be
using the camera from the iPad as your
main camera more so but what you will
notice is when you zoom in with the
iPads
the actual camera quality is quite bad
and the noise and grain is pretty heavy
for both iPads and it's no surprise at
all that the iPad Mini is forward-facing
selfie camera produces a much better
image with a seven megapixel camera
versus a 1.2 megapixel camera you are
going to get a much
a FaceTime call or just a single selfie
photo if you're looking to utilize these
features from the iPad so like I've
already said chances are you're probably
not looking at these iPads for their
specs you're looking at them to be
purpose-built towards your lifestyle so
you could be professional out there
looking for a workhorse or you could be
an average consumer out there looking
for just a media consumption base so
let's take a look at the professional
category first if you're a professional
that has to walk around all day
carry their iPad all day take a ton of
notes with the Apple pencil and really
just have to lug this thing around all
day my personal recommendation would be
the iPad Mini for the sole purpose that
it's so small so light so compact and it
doesn't feel like a burden to carry
around it's just over 200 grams and you
don't really notice it when you pick it
up when you carry it around so from a
professional point of view if you're
somebody that's just out there writing
notes taking notes and needs this thing
to be pretty much their daily driver the
iPad Mini is the best choice out of the
two but on the other hand if you're
somebody that sits in more formal
meetings day-to-day that needs a bit
more screen real estate to look at
images to blow-up images to do things a
little bit more on the creative side of
things where you need more screen real
estate well then the actual iPad iPad
which doesn't have a second name to it
is probably the better choice for you
guys with the extra large screen real
estate it is a little bit more of a
burden to carry around and you
definitely do feel the weight when
you're comparing the two it is pretty
well balanced so you don't notice it too
much but it is a burden to carry around
all day so if you're somebody that is
going into meetings and you do need some
sort of tech with you but if you open up
a full-fledged laptop everybody's going
to look at you a bit funny then the iPad
iPad is probably the best one for you
out of these two now let's say you're
not a professional you're not looking to
buy an iPad for business-related
purposes or for your work life you're
looking to buy an iPad for your own
personal joy you're looking for the iPad
to be
consumption-based to consume all the
YouTube videos out there play a few
games and no just to have a good time
with your iPad well in my personal
opinion I believe everybody's going to
steer you to the bigger larger 10.2 inch
display but I have a little bit of a
hesitation to steering you toward this
one because I don't find it as useful in
a day-to-day life purpose as an iPad
Mini everybody's phones is quite large
but they're not that large to consume a
whole bunch of content on whilst the
iPad Mini in my personal opinion is
probably just the right size for
consuming heaps of content and if we're
being completely honest with ourselves
we all probably watch content from about
20 centimeters or a so the extra screen
real estate as a memory probably won't
be too much of a difference as an added
bonus the iPad Mini also has a higher
pixel per inch ratio at 326 pixels per
inch versus the iPads 246 I believe is
off the top of my head so you're going
to get a much clearer much sharper
display from the iPad Mini with the
added benefit of the true tone display
so if you're looking for a good media
consumption device then the iPad Mini is
definitely my recommendation out of
these two even though most people will
probably steer you to the 10.2 inch
display for the sole purposes of having
a bigger display and that's all for me
guys remember don't go out and buy an
iPad for the sole purposes of specs if
one is better than the other or you're
gonna go out and pay a grand and a half
for the top-of-the-range Pro but all
you're really looking at using it for is
maybe some cooking recipes or watching a
youtube video here and there it's going
to end up in your drawer or on eBay like
the rest of the iPads you've probably
owned in the past so take a step back
think about what you're actually gonna
use this iPad for and then make your
decision based on your personal needs
not anybody else's and not the specs
themselves thanks so much for watching
guys if you haven't already make sure
you smash that subscribe button
20-19 style almost 20/20 style and as
always I'll see you next Monday